hi in this video we're gonna talk about
the basics of software we've already
covered hardware which are parts of the
computer that you can actually see and
feel with your hands software are the
programs that run on the hardware you
can't pick up a piece of software you
can pick up a piece of hardware with the
software downloaded onto it but software
is the code that is written and
imprinted on to Hardware the two main
types of software that we're going to
talk about are the operating system like
Windows Mac or Linux those are the main
three you're not really gonna get any
more than that or applications now
everything that you think of as software
probably falls into these two spaces
especially the applications applications
cover everything from your web browser
to games to things like Photoshop or
your mail how you edit documents every
type of system application that is not
an operating system is just a regular
software application the big takeaway
from this video is that hardware is what
you can actually hold on to from a
computer but software consists of all
the programs that you can run on that
hardware